[Music]
sometimes diplomacy is downright hard
you're dealing with people that you'd
really rather not be dealing with i
haven't seen you lose it ever
my relationship with madeleine albright
goes well back before either of us was
secretary of state i was a failed piano
major at the university of denver i was
about to end up teaching 13 year olds to
murder beethoven for a living and i
needed something else and i wandered
into a course
in international politics taught by a
man named joseph corbell he was
madeline's father he opened up the world
to me of things diplomatic it's a pretty
amazing story that this refugee diplomat
basically trained two women secretaries
of state when i found out she was a
republican i said condi how could you be
we have the same father
[Music]
when you're a diplomat you need to build
consensus often with people with whom
you disagree it is personal in a lot of
ways because you do have to get to know
the people put yourself into the shoes
of the person and the country that
you're dealing with so that you can come
to some agreement
finding common ground working with
people who are different those are
skills that you can use in everyday life
in whatever you do
[Music]
[Music]
you